did he or didn't say Joker is a film
that challenges its audience to
distinguish between fantasy and reality
and the task is never more harrowing
than in the final interaction between
Arthur Fleck and his would-be girlfriend
Sophie it's particularly maddening
because it's impossible to know for sure
what went down unless you have a voice
from on high to clue you in let's get to
the bottom of things and be advised
spoilers ahead the film's director Todd
Phillips recently went on record as to
whether or not Arthur actually killed
Sophie the other film's end and we'll
get to his comments in just a moment
first though let's do a little refresher
course on what happens in the movie
failed comedian Arthur slowly transforms
into the amoral clown prince of crime
after a series of humiliations
projections and outright physical
beatings it seems that the only thing
that may be helping him cling to sanity
is his burgeoning relationship with his
kind pretty neighbor Sophie one of the
only people in his life who seems to
accept him for the extremely odd
troubled man he is the final straw comes
when Arthur discovers the latter from
his extremely ill and stable mother
penny which indicates that he is the
illegitimate son of billionaire Thomas
Wayne who is in the thick of gotham
city's mayoral race after a
confrontation with wayne who tells
Arthur in no uncertain terms that his
mother is too lusion or Arthur pays a
visit to penny a visit that turns
shockingly deadly as Arthur kills his
mother and flees the scene
it's next up if Sophie's apartment and
when he arrives it becomes clear that
the relationship has all been in
Arthur's head sophie recognizes him as
nothing more than her neighbor and she
insists that he leave he does but given
his State of Mind his extremely recent
matricidal activities and the [ __ ] does
sophie is never seen again
fans have speculated that Arthur must
have done the poor girl in Joker
cinematographer Loren Shearer has played
in a whether or not Arthur killed Sophie
in the past and now Philips has
confirmed as she has take on a situation
not only is there a definitive answer
but it turns out that a scene was cut
from the film which would have confirmed
Soapy's fates a short answer is No
Arthur did not kill Sophie a simple
reason even in his twisted
it wouldn't have made sense Shearer
alluded to this when he made his remarks
to slash film in late October 2019
as he explained some people have asked
me was she killed
Phillips makes it clear she wasn't
killed Arthur is killing people who have
wronged him in a certain way and Sophie
never wronged him
Phillips expanded on this during a more
recent conversation with indieWIRE
saying quotes he doesn't kill her
definitively as the filmmaker and the
writer I'm saying he doesn't kill her
that it's almost like a little bit of a
litmus test for an audience to say well
how crazy is he Phillips went on to say
that most people he's spoken to about
the movie seem to understand that Sophie
survived and that's Arthur's Karaca
wouldn't have taken that extreme step of
doing her harm he clearly has a code he
lives by of course he did not kill this
woman down the hall and her child
Phillips went on to describe a short
deleted scene which was in to cope with
Arthur's appearance a Murray Franklin's
talk show in its a sophie was seen at
home watching the proceedings on
television with growing horror
well the scene whatever ambiguously
confirm that Arthur did indeed leave
Sophie alive and well it was cut for a
pretty darn good reason according to
Phillips we made a choice in the film to
only show everything from a Keens
perspective we curse out a great scene
with Marc Maron and Bob De Niro that
didn't involve Joaquin because it didn't
involve Joaquin everything was being
told through his point of view and
perspective so to suddenly cutter this
woman it would just literally have
changed the DNA of the film well that
certainly makes perfect sense we can't
help but think however that the side
effect of leaving Sophie's fate up in
the air may have cemented the scenes
fate Joker is a film that is absolutely
meant to be open to multiple
interpretations and the question of
whether Arthur killed his fantasy love
interest is one of the film's great
mysteries upon first viewing that
mystery though has now been solved we
wouldn't expect Phillips to shed much
light on any more of joker's
scintillating questions however up to
and including whether or not any of the
movie's events actually happened or
whether they all took place in Arthur's
troubled mind as many fans have
speculated sure we now know that sophie
is safe at the film's end unless of
she never existed at all with the movie
like Joker answers have a way of just
leading to more questions check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos by your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]